wise men talk because they have
something to say fools because they have
to say something
thinking the talking of the soul with
itself
life must be lived as play
at the touch of love everyone becomes a
poet
love is the joy of the good the wonder
of the wise the amazement of the gods
a good decision is based on knowledge
and not on numbers
[Music]
the wisest have the most authority
man is a two-legged animal without
feathers
even the gods love jokes
the punishment which the wise suffer who
refuse to take part in government is to
live under the government of worse men
the measure of the man is what he does
with power
good actions give strength to ourselves
and inspire good actions in others
a hero is born among a hundred a wise
man is found among a thousand but an
accomplished one might not be found even
among a hundred thousand men
the beginning is the most important part
of the work
we are twice armed if we fight with
faith
one of the penalties for refusing to
participate in politics is that you end
up being governed by your inferiors
[Music]
there are two things a person should
never be angry at what they can help and
what they cannot
[Music]
attention to health is life greatest
hindrance
[Music]
honesty is for the most part less
profitable than dishonesty
[Music]
the eyes of the soul of the multitudes
are unable to endure the vision of the
divine
truth is the beginning of every good to
the gods and of every good to man
the penalty good men pay for
indifference to public affairs is to be
ruled by evil men
a friend ought always to do good to a
friend and never evil
excellent things are rare
the madness of love is the greatest of
heaven's blessings
[Music]
he who is not a good servant will not be
a good master
courage is a kind of salvation
[Music]
time is the moving image of eternity
excess generally causes reaction and
produces a change in the opposite
direction whether it be in the seasons
or in individuals or in governments
they see only their own shadows or the
shadows of one another which the fire
throws on the opposite wall of the cave
the direction in which education starts
a man will determine his future in life
[Music]
self-conquest is the greatest of
victories
he whom love touches not walks in
darkness
[Music]
of all the animals the boy is the most
unmanageable
the mere athlete becomes too much of a
savage
we can easily forgive a child who is
afraid of the dark the real tragedy of
life is when men are afraid of light
people are like dirt they can either
nourish you and help you grow as a
person or they can stunt your growth and
make you wilt and die
rhetoric is the art of ruling the minds
of men
good people do not need laws to tell
them to act responsibly while bad people
will find a way around the laws
[Music]
philosophy is the highest music
[Music]
you can discover more about a person in
an hour of play than in a year of
conversation
[Music]
nothing in the affairs of men is worthy
of great anxiety
there must always remain something that
is antagonistic to good
[Music]
knowledge without justice ought to be
called cunning rather than wisdom
thinking is talking of the soul with
itself
[Music]
no one ever teaches well who wants to
teach or governs well who wants to
govern
[Music]
the most virtuous are those who content
themselves with being virtuous without
seeking to appear so
no law or ordinance is mightier than
understanding
[Music]
human behavior flows from three main
sources desire emotion and knowledge
the greatest wealth is to live content
with little
thanks for watching subscribe to the
channel wisdom of the ages